we have much more on cbs news with the
interview with president trump that's
getting a lot of attention today
the president insisted his coronavirus
response is working
and he criticized school officials in
parts of california for ordering
classrooms
not to reopen next month now after that
conversation he summoned white house
reporters to the rose garden
for a 52-minute campaign-style speech
he announced new sanctions against china
for its crackdown on hong kong
protesters
but also repeatedly blasted his expected
2020 opponent joe biden
when he was finished he spent just 10
minutes in questions and answers with
reporters
in her exclusive interview senior
investigative correspondent catherine
harris asked about a
series of issues including the pandemic
is covered 19 the greatest threat to
your reelection
i don't know i've done a great job and
now i have to do it again i was sailing
to a win
sailing we were sailing right into a win
we had the greatest economy ever for our
country and for the world
president trump accused his presumptive
rival former vice president joe biden
of already damaging the country's
recovery the possibility that joe biden
gets elected
that's a huge downward pull on the stock
market you say that's affecting the
stock market
right now oh absolutely the stock market
would be much higher
except for the fact that if he got in
the stock market will crash
the president criticized his
challenger's choice of face coverings
after he wore a mask for the first time
in public this past weekend
at a military hospital would you urge
americans to wear a mask
if it's necessary i would urge them to
wear a mask and i would say follow the
guidelines
why has it become such a political issue
it is a political issue for a lot of
people
it's not a political issue for me i
would wear it if i'm in
contact with people if i'm close to
people and the president
insisted school should open on time the
los angeles school district is the
latest
and one of the largest in the country to
say they're not going back to school
in the fall mistake what do you tell
parents and teachers
who feel that it's unsafe to go back i
would tell parents and teachers that you
should
find yourself a new person whoever's in
charge of that decision because it's a
terrible decision
because children and parents are dying
from
that trauma too they're dying because
they can't do what they're doing
mothers can't go to work because all of
a sudden they have to stay home and
watch their child and fathers
we have to open our schools we have
learned one thing very strongly young
people are
in great shape when it comes to the
coronavirus mr trump said his political
opponents
want to keep schools closed to stop his
reelection they figure if they can delay
school openings till after november
third they have an advantage in the
polls
i don't think so because joe biden has
been a failure
and after recent controversy president
trump defended the right
to display the confederate flag with me
it's freedom of speech very simple
like it don't like it it's freedom of
speech would you be comfortable with
your supporters displaying the
confederate battle flag
you know it depends on what your
definition is but i am comfortable with
freedom of speech it's very simple you
understand why the flag
is a painful symbol for many people
because it's a reminder of slavery well
people love it and i don't view
i know people that like the confederate
flag and they're not thinking about
slavery
i look at nascar you go to nesco you had
those flags all over the place they
stopped it
i just think it's freedom of speech
whether it's confederate flags or black
lives matter or anything else you want
to talk about
it's freedom of speech let's talk about
george floyd you said george floyd's
death was a
terrible thing terrible why are
african-americans still dying at the
hands of law enforcement in this country
and so are white people so are white
people
what a terrible question to ask so are
white people
more white people by the way more white
people research suggests
that black people are about three times
more likely to be killed by police than
white people
but the overall number of white people
killed is higher
because white people make up a larger
percentage of the overall population
the president also made news on china
saying for now
he does not want to continue trade talks
look we made a great trade deal
but as soon as the deal was done the ink
wasn't even dry
and they hit us with the plague okay so
right now i'm not interested in talking
to china about another deal
i'm interested in doing other things
with china and how will you hold
the chinese government accountable for
covenant you'll see yes sir
it's not for you it's for me but you
will hold them accountable you'll see
and throughout our interview the
president signaled an escalation
intentions with china he blames them for
the spread of coronavirus and damaging
the success of the u.s economy which is
key to his re-election
and bowing to opposition from hundreds
of universities the trump administration
has reversed
a week-old rule that would have barred
foreign students from continuing their
studies online
at u.s colleges gail
catherine thank you very much please
know a lot of people thank you for that
terrible question thank you very much